تداولت صفحات عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه قصه اثارت موجه من السخريه
والاستغراب لتكريم لاعب كره قدم في زامبيا
بطريقه غير معوده وقد تكون الاغربه في
العالم حيث حصل اللاعب زامبي كندي موسوندو
على خمسه اطباق من البيض لادائه الذي وصف
بالرائع خلال مباراه في نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي
الانتريه
[موسيقى]
لام من العراق
في خليجي 25
[موسيقى]
السياره الخارقه التي زعمت حركه طالبان
انتاجها ليست خارقه على ما يبدو صحف
مغربيه كشفت مفاجاه كبرى وهي ان محرك
السياره يعود لسياره اقتصاديه قديمه من
نوعيه تويوتا كورولا ولا يتوافقون مع مظهر
السياره المحرك يعود لسياره تعود لعام
2000 قام بتعديلها مهندسون من المعهد
التقني المهني الافغاني ما اثار سخريه
واسعه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
في حادثه اعتبرها رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لا تصدق تم اعتقال افراد طاقم
الخطوط الجويه الفلبينيه بتهمه تهريب
البصل من بعض دول الخليجيه بعدما ارتفعت
اسعار البصل والليمون واسعار الدجاج ولحم
البقر في الفلبين الا ان امره من كشف
واحيله منهم للتحقيق بسبب محاولتهم ادخال
المنتجات زراعيه ممنوعه الى البلاد في
حقائب الامتعه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء